Speaker 1: We have this is a disturbing story.
I want to let everybody know in advance.
This is a very, very disturbing story that
we're about to talk about.
An anti-abortion nut in her late 20s has been
caught by police.
This is really tough.
With five fetuses in her house, this is a
real headline.
I was convinced when I first saw it this this
must be bogus.
This can't possibly be real.
But it is all too real and it is horrifying.
And this seems like a very, very sick person.
D.C. police find five fetuses in the home
of anti-abortion activist Lauren Handy.
People will freak out when they hear, the
anti-abortion activists reportedly said.
Washington, D.C. police found five fetuses
in the home of an anti-abortion activists
on Wednesday.
Lauren Handi sat outside her home as officers
brought out coolers containing fetuses.
Handy declined to tell a reporter outside
her home what was there, but said people will
freak out when they hear Metro Police confirmed
to HuffPost that it found the five fetuses
after being set to investigate a tip.
So that means someone knew how sick this woman
was and they reported her, which is good.
It's a good thing that someone reported this
woman.
The police statement says upon further investigation,
MPD located five fetuses inside a residence
at the location.
The fetuses were collected by the D.C. office
of the Chief Medical Examiner.
Um, image of the woman sitting outside her
home has been published widely to Twitter.
Another article on this from NBC Washington.
Lauren Handy is one of nine people accused
of blocking access to a D.C. abortion clinic
in 2020, so this is already someone on the
radar of police for her.
I don't even to even call it anti-abortion
activism.
Sims seems not to actually take into consideration
what it is that these people do.
Police went to 28 year old Lauren had these
basement apartment and investigating a tip
about a possible biohazard material in her
house.
They collected fetuses.
It's just sick.
I'm not even going to doubt you guys get it.
OK, you guys.
This is difficult to wrap one's head around.
Did anyone know how long did she have them?
What was she going to use these fetuses for
and understand one really important thing
here?
OK?
I am guessing if you asked her or other anti-abortion
activists willing to do this, why they did
it, they would say it's to prove some kind
of point for the shock value in some kind
of anti-abortion propaganda to expose the
evils of stem cell research, embryonic stem.
I don't know what they would say, but they
would have some justification but understand
that by their own logic, these are people.
They believe that these are people.
Some of them believe at conception, some of
them believe at five weeks, some of them OK.
If you believe that a fetus is a person, you've
basically stolen human bodies from a morgue,
which is criminal.
Understand that this is by their logic and
their framework of what they believe about
this issue.
These are fully human lives, according to
them.
So this would be like keeping five dead bodies
that again by there that have been killed
by their logic.
These are some, you know, I don't know, are
these Bates Motel twists or hits?
I don't know.
But this is absolutely sick.
This is so but you know, it's sort of like
the Fox hosts who argue that they give you
the news and the truth on air.
Then they get sued for what they say, and
in court they go, We're entertainers, we're
just entertainers.
That's it.
This isn't news.
When they get sued, is it going to be an example
of the same thing?
Well, this and these are these are humans
murder the oh, but you just got caught with
five fetuses.
These are humans, right?
So this it's like having five bodies from
a morgue.
No, no, no.
This is just this is tissue.
That's all it is, these people are sick.
These people are sick, and I'm not using the
T word right what we often call the domestic,
you know what we call them?
I'm not using it because I just don't know
that it's legally appropriate.
But it's pretty damn close.
It's pretty damn close what these people do
to shift gears, and it's very hard to shift
gears from this.
I want to invite all of you to participate
in our next town hall.
We are doing a town hall, opening the phone
lines to all of our viewers, viewers and listeners.
It'll be Tuesday, April 19th at six p.m. Eastern.
It'll be live on our Packman Live channel,
really looking forward to it, really looking
forward to hearing from you guys and I'll
I'll have more reminders coming up.
Let me know your thoughts about these first
couple of stories.
Find me on Twitter at Packman.
The David Pakman Show is made possible by
our viewers.
It is the most important revenue source that
we have when people sign up at join Packman
dot com, you can now gift memberships to other
people.
But we just have too much to talk about for
me to spend too much time on that.
So I will just say, sign up at join Packman
dot com.
We would love to have you